good morning -- the rules
March seventh two thousand
nineteen is hereby called order
please be advised that audio
and video recording its case
proceed is being made it's
also being televised a man
center please call the roll
click here Cunningham Carillo
flora Sen Kamlager-Dove
Maienschein Mathis work so
your problems here previous
works we have a quorum
and we have a consent agenda
this morning is our most August
movers Camargo second of
America for a measure to
please call the roll hi
Cooley aye Cunningham Carillo
hi Carillo aye flora flora
I agree Senate Kamlager-Dove
Kamlager-Dove I Maienschein
Mathis quirk Silva hi quirk
Silva I Ramos Ramos I reverse
reverse I work side by side
motions passed thank you very
much in the schools please enter